this is a CBS News special report I'm
Tony to copal in New York the Labor
Department's newest report on weekly
unemployment claims has just come out
and we'll get you those numbers in a
moment it follows the unexpected news
last Friday that the US economy added
two and a half million jobs in the month
of May CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger joins us she has the numbers
so Jill what are they and and how do
they fit into the bigger picture and
trends regarding the economy right now
we had another one and a half million
Americans filed for unemployment
benefits last week that means that we've
now seen forty four million Americans
file I guess the good news is that we
continue to see declining levels this is
the tenth straight week but I think this
is very hard for a lot of people to
understand we've heard from a lot of you
who say hey what gives you keep saying
that we've got new people filing for
claims and yet last week we had a report
that said two and a half million
Americans went to work and the reason
that there's a problem is that these are
weekly numbers not monthly numbers and
also these weekly numbers they really
count how many people lost jobs not
people who actually have gotten jobs so
that's the big difference between the
two along with that time frame
difference yeah so Jill people pay a lot
of attention to the official
unemployment rate which right now is
13.3% but there's a lot of discussion
about whether that accurately captures
the situation out there can you walk us
through what we should know about what
the likely rate could be the monthly
report has two different surveys the one
we're talking about is called the
household survey and when the Labor
Department conducts this survey it wants
to find out why people are actually out
of work well over the last few months
people have answered that question sort
of in an unclear way the way they're
classifying themselves is the same way
we used to say that people would
classify themselves as basically on
vacation or taking the summer off the
Labor Department notes that over the
last three months the official rate is
probably understated if you look at that
13.3% that we talked about last Friday
it's probably sixteen point three
percent going back to April the fourteen
plus percent month in unemployment it
was probably
closer to 20% the bureau is trying to
rectify these issues it knows that they
have issues but this is such a strange
situation Tony it's hard to help people
understand what the way the way they
answer these questions has a huge impact
on that top line reading yeah but even
if the unemployment rate is sixteen
point six percent that is lower than
projected and there is some evidence
that the worst is behind us in terms of
the pace of decline and there is a
possibility that a rebound has begun
though it may take some time Jill
Schlesinger thank you very much